thank you very much time was when he
walked into this place as first minister
how time has changed i swear by almighty
god
that i'll tell the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth
this was alex salmond the witness in
this parliament's history
his story as he told it was of treachery
and betrayal by old friends
not before he railed against the
institutions in the country
he once led the failures of leadership
are many and obvious
and yet convener not a single person has
taken
responsibility not a single resignation
not a single sacking not even an
admonition
the scottish civil servant hasn't failed
its leadership
has failed the crown office hasn't
failed
its leadership has failed scotland
hasn't failed
its leadership has failed
the former first minister said his
successor nicola sturgeon
had breached the ministerial code and
spoke of a meeting in march 2018
that she said she'd forgotten april the
second that year is when nicola sturgeon
told the scottish parliament she first
learned of complaints against alex
salmond
when they met in her house she said it
was an snp
party matter and so no records were kept
as they should be with government
business
but there was a meeting in her office
four days before that on the 29th of
march
on one account to arrange the one four
days later
on the government business of a
government investigation
sky news revealed last july that a
witness who attended that meeting
discussed with nicolas sturgeon
complaints against alex hammond
that doesn't square with the account
that the first minister gave to the
scottish parliament
it was only after we reported the
content of that meeting
the nicola sturgeon addressed it saying
she'd forgotten
it had taken place under the ministerial
code the correct thing to do would have
been to correct the record
as timelessly as possible as opposed to
waiting
18 months to sky news broadcast it
alex hammond took the committee back to
january 2019
and his successful legal challenge
against the government investigation
into complaints against him that they
were tainted by apparent bias
the scottish government had ignored
legal warnings they would lose he said
in the hope he would be arrested if the
criminal case had been advanced
then the civil case wouldn't have gone
ahead pending
the outcome in the criminal case and
many people seem to invest a great deal
of hope
that the criminal case would ride to the
rescue
like the cavalry over the hill and
somehow the civil case would never be
heard
with his departure alex salmon clears
the way for part two of this political
drama
nicola sturgeon will appear as the
second half of hollywood's double bill
next week
new questions for her are raised by
answers from him
james matthews sky news edinburgh